le salut bien se marier
encore une belle journée
laser sur le cul oui ça fait déjà un
mois donc il est temps d'y retourner
pour ma douzième séance déjà et comme
d'habitude à copenhague
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
donc je tombe pas de l'oeil c'est toi
[Musique]
anesthésiés naturel
voilà donc c'était la 12e séance ça
commence à faire mine de rien pour mon
prono fessier qui j'ai connu des poulets
qui avait été moins requis et du bacon
qui a été moins de risques que ça et
alors donc pas aujourd'hui on a continué
en mode mitraillette
comme la dernière fois vous souvenez
c'est à dire puissance et fréquence
maximale à fond le médecin a juste de
modifier un peu la longueur d'un pacte
non c'est un truc un peu technique mais
bon voilà l'impact reste sous la nano
secondes
donc ça reste super super court ce qui
est la particularité du pico sur picot
show toujours pas comment on dit voilà
j'en avais parlé d'ailleurs je
l'expliqué un peu tout ça dans une
précédente vidéo regardez là après c'est
vous s'il vous plaît alors en termes de
douleur bah c'était assez comparable à
la fois précédente c'est à dire un petit
peu plus douloureux que juste avant
probablement lié au fait que l'on soit
puissances et les fréquences maximales
mais bon il faut ce qu'il faut
malgré tout grâce à la pommade
anesthésiante ça reste vraiment sans
comparaison avec mes précédentes séances
avec le cul switch il a même re passer
un petit coup sûr les yeux je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez
depuis deux trois séances la laisser là
cette zone là au repos alors les yeux
pas les miens ceux de cyril on avait
laissé la zone au repos parce que la
peau avait été vraiment bien abîmée par
mais toutes dernières séances avec
l'ancien laser a par contre on va on va
changer un petit peu notre notre petit
cérémonial pour surveiller l'évolution
du des tatouages parce que je me suis
dit que ça rime pas à grand-chose en
fait de vous montrer les photos juste
après la séance et puis le lendemain à
cloud trois jours et s'est vu que pour
vous avoir en effet pour que ce soit
vraiment
visible à l'oeil nu il faut attendre
trois à quatre semaines
donc bon mais ça on va en reparler après
donc photo quand même parce que je sais
que c'est ce que vous êtes venu chercher
un vendu comme des petits cochons ça
c'est le tatouage il ya un mois juste
avant la séance il ya un mois voilà et
ça c'est mon tatouage ce matin au moment
où je vous parle c'est à dire juste
avant la séance du jour
eneria un mois entre les deux vous avez
peut-être trouvé que qui se passe pas
grand chose mais en fait si vraiment je
trouve que depuis depuis les deux
dernières séances là ça ça ça progresse
quand même ça rend mal en photo désolé
mais moi à l'oeil nu je vois que les
traits continue à continuer à te lire et
même à certains endroits ils
disparaissent un genre par exemple là et
là aussi un peu et bon à d'autres
endroits aussi mais c'est quand même
mieux
vraiment oui alors je vous vois rigoler
un vous vous dites oh mais de ce fait de
l'auto persuasion vraiment très
clairement
donc je vous jure que en vrai c'est très
net il est en train de se passer quelque
chose pour de vrai alors évidemment on
va vous allez être obligés de me croire
sur parole un parce que vous n'allez pas
pouvoir venir vérifier en personne non
mais vraiment c'est non et alors on a
fait un petit truc
l'ami roma parce que on nous l'a demandé
dans les commentaires la dernière fois
nous a concocté un petit objet
multimédia un pommeau que je vous laisse
admirer pour mieux vous rendre compte
[Musique]
on
donc vous voyez soyez un petit peu
honnête il se passe quelque chose c'est
long ça je ne dis pas mais il se passe
quelque chose comme bon alors un truc
que je voulais vous dire tout à l'heure
où seul pour les trois quatre semaines
pour pouvoir juger de l'efficacité du
laser en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
vous avez été hyper nombreuses et hyper
nombreux à m'envoyer la même vidéo là il
ya quelques jours c'est une vidéo que
quatre vingt dix a posté sur son profil
instagram 90 que ça fait là neuf qui
travaille chez sephora là mais ce n'est
pas tout et surtout on peut rigoler deux
membres et donc alors là elle a posté
une séances de détatouage que qu'a eu
son mari est donc parmi tous ceux et
toutes celles d'entre vous qui m'ont
gentiment renvoyé cette cette vidéo y en
a plein qui m'ont dit mais c'est fou je
viens d'y aller il ya des techniques
manifestement qui marche comme ça à la
pâte direct instantanément pourquoi
pourquoi ça marche pas comme ça pour toi
donc alors c'est très gentil mais non
c'est vraiment méfiez vous de ce que
vous voyez c'est pas du tout comme ça
que ça se passe c'est que c'est vraiment
extrêmement trompeurs comme vidéo et
c'est même assez marrant parce que c'est
en voyant ce genre de vidéos avant que
j'ai eu l'idée de tester le truc pour
éprouver le fait est démontré que non
c'est pas un truc miracle le laser qui
marche comme ça en un coup en rage en
avait déjà parlé dans une vidéo
précédente mais je remet une petite
couche parce que des vidéos comme ça il
y en a plein internet donc déjà petit
petit rappel le laser il fait exploser
lancre en morceaux suffisamment petit
pour qu'elle puisse être éliminé par
l'organisme mais ça l'élimination par
l'organisme si le si l'explosion de
l'anc et immédiate l'élimination par
l'organisme ça se passe après très
progressivement ce n'est pas instantané
donc il faut c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut laisser trois quatre
semaines avant de pouvoir juger de
l'efficacité d'un traitement laser ch/le
un laser comme ça comment pourrait on
avoir l'impression sur cette vidéo qui
fait disparaître le tatouage
instantanément ça n'existe pas ça n'est
pas possible
alors en fait qu'est ce qui donne cette
impression bat vraiment c'est tout con
le laser donc il fait exploser lancre
c'est ce qui fait ce petit bruit
et toutes ces petites explosions là elle
soulève la partie superficielle de notre
peau qui s'appelle l'épiderme
voilà donc provoque un une espèce de
décollement de l'épiderme et comme
lancre elle est en dessous
elle est entre l'épiderme et le derme le
décollement ça fait qu' on ne voit plus
lancre mais elle est toujours là elle
ait explosé mais elle est toujours là et
cette espèce de réaction cette espèce de
truc blanc qu'on voit à la surface et
qui masque lancre ça me le fait à moi
aussi
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
impressionnant sur des vidéos comme
celle de 2,90 parce que le laser pour
moi il passe sur un trait 1 donc c'est
un faisceau kiev 1 alors que là il passe
sur un gros aplats de couleurs à une
grosse surface avec un faisceau qui est
très large
du coup bas la surface qui réagit elle
est beaucoup plus grande
ça saute aux yeux mais une fois que
l'épiderme se recolle après quelques
minutes lancre elle réapparaît
voilà donc ça c'était pour ma ma
douzième séance
et cette petite cette petite mise au
point le prochain rendez-vous est dans
un mois et demi et par mois voilà on
espace un petit peu c'est le protocole
notamment quand on allonge un peu la
durée de la durée de l'impact c'est
comme ça que c'est comme ça que ça se
passe
avant ce que je vais faire je vous
l'avais annoncé la dernière fois dans la
vidéo je vais faire une vidéo pour
répondre moi pas une vraie faculté si un
petit peu au sens premier du terme
je vais répondre aux questions que vous
me posez le plus souvent quand je vous
croise dans la rue
dans le train dans le métro pour nous
elle fait ce dans un bar
bon vous l'avez vous avez l'idée voilà
parce qu'on est vraiment on pose très
souvent les bonnes questions
donc je vais lui répondre une bonne fois
pour toutes d'ici là à écouter qu'est ce
qui se passe bas mettez vous bien et
puis surtout
[Musique]